hey guys Ryan right here hi I'm Selina
Meyers so today we're going to check out
a video from button poetry Sabrina the
name doing a poem explaining my
depression to my mother
I've actually actually up let me get her
because we did one of Shame cuckoo quick
sing yeah we did one of his videos and
chelina and bronze color my energy which
features a lot of artists a lot of poems
so yeah let's check this out and see if
we can understand and decipher this poem
a little bit break it apart break it
down I hope I catch every word
explaining my depression to my mother a
conversation mom my depression is a
shape-shifter one day it is as small as
a firefly in the palm of a bear the next
it's the bear on those days I play dead
until the bear leaves me alone I call
the bad days the dark days mom says try
lighting candles when I see a candle I
see the flesh of a church the flicker of
the flame sparks of a memory younger
than noon I am standing beside her open
casket it is the moment I learn every
person I ever come to know someday die
besides mom I'm not afraid of the dark
perhaps that's part of the problem mom
said I thought the problem was that you
can't get out of bed I can't
anxiety holds me a hostage inside of my
house inside of my head mom says where
did anxiety come from anxiety is the
cousin visiting from out of town
depression felt obligated to bring to
the party mom I am the party only I am a
party I don't want to be at mom says why
don't you try going to actual parties
see your friends sure I make plans I
make plans but I don't want to go I make
plans because I know I should want to go
I know sometimes I would have wanted to
go it's just not that much fun having
fun when you don't want to have fun mom
you see mom each night insomnia sweeps
me up in his arms dips me in the kitchen
in the small glow of the stove light
insomnia has this mo Mantic way the moon
feels like perfect company mom says try
counting sheep but my mind can only
count reasons to stay awake so I go for
walks but my stuttering kneecaps Clank
like silver spoons held in strong arms
with loose wrists they ring in my ears
like clumsy church bells reminding me I
am sleepwalking on an ocean of happiness
I cannot baptize myself in Mom's and
happy it's a decision but my happy is as
hollow as a pinprick peg
my happy is a high fever naught will
break mom says I am so good I'm making
something out of nothing and then flat
out asked me if I am afraid of dying no
I am afraid of living mom I am lonely I
think I learned good out my dad left how
to turn the anger into lonely the lonely
into busy so when I tell you I've been
super busy lately I mean I've been
falling asleep watching SportsCenter on
the couch to avoid confronting the empty
side of my bed but my depression always
drags me back to my bed until my bones
are the Forgotten fossils of a skeleton
sunken city my mouth a boneyard of teeth
broken from biting down on themselves
the hollow auditorium of my chest
swoons with echos of a heartbeat but I
am a careless tourist here I will never
truly know everywhere I have been mom
still doesn't understand mom can't you
see that neither can I
how's it tense right right you never
tell me what kind of buh-bye or what
yeah you know I'm very glad Wow Wow
you're right yeah okay okay
yeah I've seen young you're not honey I
think you need us a would be breath
together
ever ever ever
sorry I'm emotional no no I'm just
joking I'm just I gotta say you know
before deciphering this poem like that
voice she has her level of expression
was beautiful like I've seen a lot of
people do spoken word and most of the
time I kind of find their way of
delivery or their words honestly I find
a lot of it kind of pretentious but she
was very raw and yeah the emotion was
very much like a time so guys she was
not to breakdown right I think that made
like me like that made me trigger to
like if I anyone else said that poem but
like you know and just like read it I
wouldn't give me that same effect I love
how the poem was an expressive towards
her mom because trying to get your
parents to understand your level of
depression can be hard because
especially parents sometimes they'll
kind of go into denial about it and they
don't really acknowledge the truth of it
they'll just throw it vice at you
without trying to really grasp the
gravity of the situation and to see that
you know she's like really trying to get
through to her mom about how dark and
depressed her life is this is like
serious major depression this is like a
condition almost thing what she's
speaking about and depression isn't
something that it's more than just a
mood like this depression can be
something that really does take over
your life your whole lifestyle it's like
I know what it's like where for many
years depression was like my comfort
zone you know like that's where you felt
like you belong it's where you felt like
you deserve to be
so you felt like it was home and
happiness was uncomfortable and it felt
like you would just I still go through
that like when a lot of great things are
happening sometimes my mind goes okay
once it's all gonna fall apart you know
like one just gonna crash like what's
your limit of happiness that you can
have what's the maximum you can endure
but yeah anyway sorry I keep talking no
I'm listening
good I want this whole video to be you
listening yeah I'll be inside no well I
mean when you were saying how you're how
you know a lot of parents would give
advice or you know they don't know how
to react to it or a lot of parents I
feel I have like a lot of guilt like you
don't even want to tell your parents how
you feel because you don't like it makes
you feel worse yeah then they feel
guilty about it and it's like you don't
want them feel guilty about it that is a
support it's understandable because
parents you know they love you so much
that it's that kind of thing like if my
girlfriend is really down my first
instant like I know I should just be
understanding I should talk to her
listen to her let her open up but my
first instinct that I usually don't act
on but I want to just give a bunch of
advice because I want to make her feel
bad and they know not always a lot of
the time I feel like people know the
advice I feel like people already know
where they want to be what they have to
do but what limits them is not being
able to have a connection with people of
being understood first now I'm being
allowed to feel your feelings so you can
let go with them a lot of time did we
just block them or we just let it out a
little bit I'm sick of talking about it
you know like it's it's something that
sometimes the pain can be so deep that
you keep talking about it you might
sound like you're on repeat but that's
what eventually does lead to being able
to accept hearing this poem it's it's
weird it's like semi inspiring to me
simply because of a level of expression
that she has but it's powerful like as
I've seen a lot of a lot of poems are
about depression and anger but I like
how she was saying like anger turns into
loneliness loneliness turns into being
busy because one thing that I do is when
I'm really down is I get super lazy or I
get super [ __ ] busy and it's funny
how being busy
can mask like a lot of us and say I
especially think in America we put a lot
of our personal value into what our
career equals man you know we don't
think about our personal life we think
more about what about our worth it's
just money or drugs everything but
that's not even true though no it's not
like if you don't have your personal
life in balance then the career stuff
won't even [ __ ] matter to Danny
definitely but I should apply that more
because all I care about is doing
YouTube videos you are living the dream
I don't care about personal life hey
aren't even on my girlfriend's last name
for 10 years anyway guys thanks for
sending depression our way if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Selena's
Channel
you're gonna get a good idea what she's
like on there total just what no I I
wanted them to interpret what the what
is if I just yeah just then they can put
in the rest you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers we can get
product placement for things such as
toasted coconut cashews toasted coconut
cashews are wonderful they're [ __ ]
delicious and cashews help with your sex
performance yeah they're very good for
your brain to help you remember things
as well exactly so you can remember the
sensations of the man or woman that you
were having sex with for example I know
a lot of girls like to have a penis in
the vagina catchers have got me to
remember that we were almost sincere the
whole video almost it's not my stuff
it's okay she talks about depression
lean it's a loneliness anger mine
converts into humor I just mask all my
pain with humor
Oh Cassius